With respect to the three other solutions, we have advantages and
disadvantages as well.
As far as the ADT, Abstract Data Type solution, it's very good,
as far as maintainability and reuse.
Those particular components could be used in other applications by just,
just plucking them out.
Remember, they've hidden away details.
On the other hand because things are hidden away you have to
invoke them through function call interfaces which might be more expensive, so
you might pay a price in performance.
With respect to implicit implication,
okay it has also maintainability advantages.
If you change the representation because the, the, the clients and the servers
don't know much about each other you only have to change them in one place.
You don't have to change change the others, which also facilitates reuse.
On the other hand, because it's implicit invocation and
you don't know who you're talking to a lot of times,
it's sometimes difficult to think about or control what's going on.
And if you had to do some kind of debugging it might be tricky to know,
you know, which of the components was responsible for some kind of problem.
Also, as with the ADT solution, because you have these more or
less abstract interfaces between things there may be a performance hit.
With respect to pipe and filter, pipe and
filter is very intuitive, easy to think about.
It's also easy to reuse because each of the filters along the way,
you can plunk out and put into another, another solution.
On the other hand if we wanted to make changes,
such as making the system interactive pipe and filter wouldn't work at all.
It, it's going to stream things, stream things through.
also, it's not particularly space efficient because you have
no no place for you to store the data, which means you
might have multiple copies of that data floating around as you're processing.
So, each of the particular solutions has advantages and disadvantages, and
in any particular sit, situation you want to look at what's important to you.
Is performance important?
Is memory footprint important?
And, pick a solution that has the particular advantages that you need and
avoids the particular disadvantages that might bother you.